All right, let's get to hatred. What mail
for the week? A quick reminder, if you don't
know what Patriot mail is, it is when a professional
voiceover artist does interpretive readings
of the hate mail that I receive. Take a listen
[inaudible]
it's like email forwards from your racist
grandma on steroids.
[inaudible]
Patriot mail written by Patriots who hate
David Pacman because America and because freedom.
Yeah, so this one, this hatred mail actually
gets at something that we've, we've been talking
about for a little while and it's the idea
of me being a sort of hidden socialist of
some kind. Take a listen to this.
You sir are a ignorant socialist one. A B.
I had the displeasure of listening to about
30 seconds of your horrible degrading and
accurate radio show after that 30 seconds
that you were merely in this business to do
people out of money. So you would not have
to do physical labor. In conclusion, I hope
the flees of a thousand camels infest your
bed at night while you sleep.
Listen, why would I only be a socialist wannabe,
right? I mean, number one, this is my show.
Like there's no risk to me getting fired if
I was a socialist, I would just say I'm a
socialist. But more importantly, if I were
a socialist, socialism is viewed the most
positively right now by society in the United
States that it's been viewed in decades. Like
what is the big advantage to me being a socialist,
but hiding it from you day in and day out
and claiming that I'm actually a social Democrat.
I I've, why wouldn't I just say it if I were
a socialist? So this is the, we've heard this
one before. It falls very, very flat. And
the best way to fight against nonsense like
this is to take advantage of the coupon code
hatred, 40 H a T R I O T four zero.
When you use that coupon code upon signing
up or in order to sign up for a membership
on my website, you save 40% and it is like
a double middle finger to the hatred. It's
you're telling them, not only am I not convinced
by your hatred, schism, I am going to support
the David Pakman show with the coupon code
hatred 40 join pacman.com takes under a minute.